[Applaudissements]
ils rêvaient tous d'un autre tirage mais
finalement le sort en a décidé autrement
le football-club de versailles
rencontrera à l'extérieur en quarts de
finale de la coupe de france l'autre
petit poucet de la compétition bergerac
deux clubs de nationale 2 chacun leader
de sa poule en championnat et chacun
déterminés à accéder au dernier carré au
delà de jouer bergerac on est surtout
triste de devoir recevoir pour notre
public or ça reste un match de coupe
quand même mais c'est surtout une place
qui jouant pour la demi finale et on va
te donner de façon on se dit que tout
est possible pour aller en demi finale a
réuni lundi soir pour assister à
l'annoncé des prochaines affiches les
joueurs devront donc attendre encore un
peu pour espérer affronter l'un des
clubs de ligue 1 encore en compétition
marseille nantes ou encore monaco en
attendant le déplacement à bergerac et
vainqueur de metz et saint-etienne au
tour précédent est loin d'être gagné
d'avancé
ça nous laisse une chance de dépasser en
demi finales même si c'est une équipe
très sérieuse contre laquelle on va
jouer chez eux sur leur terrain ça va
être un peu compliqué mais on va se
donner les moyens de passer la rencontre
se jouera le 9 février à 18h30 mais quel
que soit le résultat il y aura bien un
club de nationale 2 en demi finale de
coupe de france cette année